Jun jube otherwise a Jew
cool place so use the drain sewers as a
mean to
yes they were built to divert water from
an underground spring and are quite
spacious it seemed only natural to
incorporate it into the overall
structure but we weren't using it not
today I really wonder when someone who
is seasonal and when the civilian run is
dry the camp tunnels produce a rather
poisonous type ha oh I wonder if I take
damage there is an antidote of course
but we won't be bothering with it today
it's gonna scare me when it's very good
we're almost there I guess I gotta get
up somewhere there maybe I'm down here
it's dark
greatest
what does that mean
even water nothing is everything is
standing in my way
all right
less confusing
it stares them
maybe I can jump on it
haha
if I jump really hard
why do I even bother trying
came from there I need to be sit I can't
go down
so yeah at least me confused
first time playing this game
go greased lightning
maybe I miss
Greece let's read the notes I'm sleeping
to enter the sewer it must first be
drained well I don't maybe I don't want
to enter that's
vessel is needed to camp up
go sit there and we gotta grease grease
lightning all right I like this place
well lit up
[ __ ] you
off you go
and you're going down [ __ ] yes I am
that's every day climbing ladders
wonder where I should go all right
wow I feel tall
aleksander knew that near there must be
a way to finish a ritual before it was
too late you had to teach his friend to
harvest the bite a kind of foggy in here
just nasty
there and a room
at least has a skull on it let's leave
that for later
yeah
this looks like a hustle part
yeah it's definitely a possible place
I got 20 tender muxes that's insane
what's going on here what I do exactly
all right lift that up know what's
that's good for
uh-huh we got to lift up
a free lift up stand here and didn't
wait for something to happen well I
think mmm it's getting
oh this had a shine bright light to it
let's give this
what was that
spare me
look I made 10 bucks and a note I don't
know if though bucks
all right
I guess Allenby
it's stuck as well
another one of those
all right thoughts you
on her leaves though that is the monster
I bet he's like a pro it's just trying
to help me
this isn't his way doing things without
that it's done
is we've got an offer to the scholar
room
I got a feeling I'm gonna need these
all right
there is the way out good Irena horrible
otherwise
okay so another room another challenge
another one of these thank you
back to you later young man all right
mocks machine there are finally some
clue what the hell I'm doing the 13th of
13 of January night 1799 the work I've
put into this machine is unequaled by
the reasoning of any man the thought
that generations of men have passed away
since I first attempted to reconstruct
the design is most tiring the limitation
of this world have made my work
incredibly difficult it has forced me to
build a thing almost a hundred times
larger than the delicate contraption it
tries to emulate not to mention the flow
of tamed lightly crudely replaced by
pressure steam pushing its way through
pipes and turbines it shames me to think
of what the inventor would have thought
of my monster where he works with a
magnifying glass to carefully fix all
the parts I push five men to erect our
erect a tower of wrought iron in the
hope it will have even the tiniest hint
of power found in a traveler's locket
okay I didn't leave much and
I thought it was blood there is blood
why not
stuck
I think they're right check out the
other rooms
that's why the [ __ ] not same [ __ ] name
see what you can find though we got [ __ ]
is that
wouldn't crank
what do you Dan crank this for I crank
for a machine
all right these rooms are almost
identical
all right
uh-huh
hustle salt
oh it did so awesome
what do you know
I wonder if animal assault is that
quickly
another deaf machine
as there's an exit like exits
why
as a boatful pen that's great
oh that was exit I came from man I'm
stupid all right
oh I don't feel as scared